[Música]
noticias desde la salud con más Romero
sala amar Buen día para usted Buenos
días Ángela hoy un caso impresionante
una curación por VIH que se reportó este
lunes si es el tercero en remisión de
infección que es un término que
prefieren usar algunos médicos para no
hablar de curación porque hay muchos
matices un poco polémico es la primera
vez es una de las primeras la tercera
Perdón vez que está tantos años no son
ya cuatro años Aunque hay otros que
siguen en estudio es decir que podemos
tener casos parecidos en los próximos
años escuchemos el informe preparado por
Juan Pablo lucumí
no hay rastro del VIH ni en su sangre ni
en su tejido este fue el hallazgo que la
revista nature publicó en un comunicado
este lunes es el tercer caso de cura del
virus que produce el SIDA se trata de un
hombre de 53 años de dusseldorf Alemania
que prefirió permanecer anónimo al
conocer la noticia los dos casos de
éxito anteriores fueron en Berlín en
2009 y en Londres en 2019 y ahora
anunciamos un tercer caso que es el
paciente de tusoldorf es un caso que
también se integra en el equipo icem y
donde
hemos hecho un trasplante hematológico
con células madre de un donante que
tiene una mutación especial Que impide
que el virus penetre en las células Esto
hace que se reconstituya un nuevo
sistema inmunitario y Esto hace que el
virus no pueda penetrar en las células
porque le falta precisamente una puerta
de entrada una proteína que es esencial
para que penetre dentro de la célula del
virus
Y es que los tres pacientes tenían algo
en común padecían de cáncer de sangre y
fueron tratados con un trasplante de
médula que renovó casi por completo su
sistema inmune pero los científicos
dicen que no se podría aplicar el mismo
procedimiento en todos los casos Pues el
trasplante de médula es un proceso
complicado y peligroso y muchas veces
está disponible solo para un pequeño
número de pacientes sin embargo para uno
de los tres hombres sanos se trata de un
suceso que hay que celebrar los últimos
40 años en el desarrollo de una cura
para el VIH la prueba viva de eso soy yo
que a pesar de que ya no tengo VIH sigo
y seré siempre miembro de la comunidad
VIH
porque son sobrevivientes como del
cáncer son sobrevivientes del VIH aparte
de los tres pacientes confirmados de
Berlín Londres y dusseldorf hay otros
dos casos de remisión de VIH pendientes
para un trasplante uno de Nueva York y
otro de California Estados Unidos
quienes podrían también tener a la
ciencia de su lado y cantar Victoria en
la batalla contra el sida
estos casos son evidentemente
decepcionales qué caminos se abren para
hallar una cura el VIH Sí vamos a
repasar por ahora por ahora Cuáles han
sido estos casos y ver qué vías nos
están investigando a raíz de esto por un
lado tenemos estos trasplantes de
células madre que es este caso no a raíz
del trasplante de la médula pero también
se han dado hay una paciente de Nueva
York que fue con trasplante de células
madre desde un cordón umbilical como
decíamos Esto no es aplicable también lo
decía el informe no porque por ejemplo
en un trasplante de médula tienen una
supervivencia del 40% sólo se hacen
casos de pacientes de leucemia que no
respondan a ningún otro tratamiento
Entonces al ser tan arriesgado no se
puede aplicar Pero puede abrir esta
puerta estas terapias genéticas No esta
mutación que recibieron al recibir este
trasplante Pues están intentando
emularla in vitro digamos en
laboratorios intentar modificar las
células de los pacientes para que luego
queden así blindados a la infección del
VIH sin la necesidad de un trasplante
otros casos de remisión que se son los
pacientes llamados controladores
postratamiento no que son los pacientes
que después de años con
antirretrovirales o con terapias también
de sistema inmune logran controlar Pues
de forma Autónoma sin necesidades de
tratamientos o demás medicamentos el
virus y esta infección de VIH esto
también es el caso por ejemplo de
paciente de Barcelona no y se intenta
investigar esto para intentar replicar
lo que haya sucedido con estos pacientes
con terapias inmunes No como intentar
reforzar el sistema inmune de los
propios pacientes y por último están los
controladores llamados de élite que con
este nombre tan impresionante lo que
logran es controlar la infección por sí
solo sin ningún tipo de tratamiento y
quizás en los más complejos de entender
porque implican muchos factores hay
factores genéticos hay factores de los
sistemas inmunes de las propias personas
y también se ha visto que los virus En
estos casos de controladores de élite
tenían algunas algunos defectos que
permitieron que fuera más fácil este
control Pero bueno todo esto son pistas
digamos para para podemos estar de
acuerdo en que es una noticia de
esperanzadora no es una noticia
esperanzadora Sí bueno y vamos a hacer
un cambio radical de tema para hablar de
la Alimentación en niños y jóvenes
porque hay nuevos datos sobre esta
materia tan conversada si se trata de un
estudio publicado en la revista Llama
pediátrix por la universidad española de
castilla-la Mancha y la cifra principal
es que el 22% de niños y niñas entre 6 y
18 años viven con lo que han llamado una
conducta alimentaria alterada y además
hay una diferencia de género muy marcado
30% en niñas y mujeres jóvenes y 17% en
niños y hombres jóvenes claramente es
algo que puede afectar a todo el mundo
Pero hay una diferencia un sesgo de
género claramente marcado con estos
datos A qué se refieren con conductas
alimentarias alteradas Pues estamos
hablando por ejemplo de ponerse a dieta
para adelgazar sin ningún motivo de
salud detrás de eso comer por atracones
un ejercicio excesivo tomar laxantes o
diuréticos para adelgazar son digamos
pasos previos a trastornos de conductas
alimentarias no tienen por qué terminar
luego con un diagnóstico médico pero que
definitivamente son digamos ese primer
paso de riesgo y para el cierre hablemos
de Estos factores de riesgo que señala
ese mismo estudio Sí pues primero habla
de una correlación de edad no Cuantos
más años Cuanto más adolescentes De
hecho no teniendo en cuenta que estamos
hablando entre 6 y 18 años más riesgo
hay por supuesto también Esa diferencia
de género que estábamos diciendo como
veíamos antes y también hay otra
relación con lo que con el índice de
masa corporal que recordemos en este
espacio no lo vamos a hablar como un
indicador de salud sino como un simple
cálculo entre altura y peso entonces las
personas con más peso respecto a su
altura más riesgo tenían también de
tener estas conductas alimentarias
alteradas todos estos factores de riesgo
como estamos viendo son factores
sociales que no tienen que ver
necesariamente con una tema de salud que
no tienen que estar vinculados y que nos
hablan también de la cultura no de la
dieta de la presión estética que nos
afecta y que afecta a niños y a jóvenes
en muy tempranas edades y también desde
la falta de atención con diferenciados
en el sistema de salud No claro tener
estos datos ayuda también a hacer
políticas que lo intenten prevenir vale
el agradecimiento para usted como
siempre y nos vemos mañana Muchas
gracias Ángela